on va jouer maintenant d'idiot parce
qu'on aime bien jouer le vendredi je
sais que my eyes thomas sauterait joie
ont ragé pour savoir qui est le plus
poissard de tous
à chaque fois vous allez voir deux
personnes vont s'affronter venir là
devant et s'affronter y aura de vente e
regardez bien la maison deux objets en
apparence si d'autres identique sauf que
l'un est piégée et l'autre non d'engins
des shots
oh non il y a non un petit jus de tomate
sympathique
dans l'autre choc il y a de la harissa
aliénant et fin du tabasco là c'est
pareil quoi c'est l'horreur c'est
l'horreur
[Applaudissements]
c'est les cas qui alloue qui a loose et
oui la mousse à raser à danser à thomas
thomas j'ai besoin de vous
photo marc thomas je vais vous mettre de
la mousse à raser dans une des neuf de
vos deux mains de dos voilà comme ça et
les filles vont choisir une dès demain
et vous ferez le bonjour de la pieuvre
soit sans mousse soit avec mousse
arriva
les à la moins chanceuses vous allez
tous les deux appuyez ensemble sur
l'interrupteur de se ses cheveux l'un
est branché l'autre non donc non sera
temps farine est lourd à l'autre et non
sa logique à 2 3 go non mais c'est comme
ça les voilà lalalalalalalalala
c'est bien
[Musique]
l'été
ces désastres en cette séquence où le
monde est salée le truc est en train de
fumer
qu'est-ce qui va alors là alors les
filles annoncé à un sceau du coin génial
c'est mon préféré regarde pas de nom moi
comme ça qu'on a envie de bien qu'on ait
une vie de merde on est vite pris en
otage
[Musique]
jusqu'au début du jeu c'était vous avez
un seau avec quelque chose dedans
l'autre saut sans rien et elle devait à
la veuve se jeter à la face de l'europe
et de l'assiette mais c'était pour une
soupe comme une espèce de futures
brusques hausses très inquiet donc voilà
alors nadège c'est foutu aléas monde
info.com
4' quatre candidats kamel mouassa qui
sera le plus poissard des cas vraiment
le méga giga plus bas 2 3
à
la mort quand il y un demi pouce à damas
des essais
[Applaudissements]